[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
tron est donné
[Musique]
dijon est basé
on va chercher du temps s'il est tombé
bernicat 6 heures on vient le chercher
chez moi mais moi je t'écoute et brach
couper les veines de céder 10 milliards
d'euros
[Musique]
les conduire à donner
hélas intitulé on sait par des bruits de
rendu gecko me
kuhn et ses bras comme un des premiers
feedbacks des gros bonnets mai soit si
l'on se fie aux majors aux mamans si
torres capturé par les militants comme
abidal que tu me supporter ton d'arvida
raffiné de la taille et du ballon
[Applaudissements]
aie aie
[Musique]
adecco
à l'innovation
oh
gr
[Applaudissements]
merci d'être là merci d'être là on le
quitte et regarde ce que j'ai pour toi
je les fais cette nuit c'est un disque
de platine
quand vous mangez
franchement c'est la révélation l'année
c'est un carton on le kif
il a un look de ouf ça va frérot est
franchement j'étais beau gosse a plus
qu'à merci merci
ça me fait plaisir mathieu voix vous me
disais que je vous kiffe y est comme ça
nous connaissent et nino pas alors en
vrai je suis passé un tout petit peu à
côté du phénomène je dois reconnaître je
n'en ai scud lui là encore il encore non
mais parce que lui il encore sur francis
cadre à la baignade les rats et les
bloquer il est bloqué années 80 on aime
beaucoup francis cabrel aussi mais bon
cru et ce soit avec plein de gens
célèbres
ouais ouais les suivants il peut être
pote avec moi on peut te rencontrer pas
de souci je tape en tout 150 mille
albums de comme prévu ont été vendus en
moins de deux mois c'est un carton et
c'est mérité
bravo change rien on te kiffe et tu
reviens de voir quand tu veux merci
disons merci merci
[Applaudissements]
juste
le carton a léché
[Applaudissements]